[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 les titres de ce lundi
25 septembre les élections sénatoriales
ont livré leur verdict hier les noms des
six sénateurs du département sont connus
parmi eux des nouveaux qui sont-ils
quels sont les enseignements à tirer de
ce scrutin dont le département chronique
au début de cette édition
elles sont le premier démonstrateur
d'agriculture urbaine en économie
circulaire les ferments ville de saint
cyr l'école ont reçu le prix défi urbain
qui récompense les projets de villes
durables
pour en parler nous recevons alexis
lefebvre chef de projet à l'association
le vivant est la ville qui a lancé
l'initiative
enfin du sport à la fin de ce journal
avec un classique qui fêtait son 40e
anniversaire le paris versailles étaient
au programme hier quelques 25 mille
coureurs ont pris le départ de la
compétition
mais avant d'ouvrir ce journal journée
d'action aujourd'hui contre la réforme
du code du travail mobilisation à
l'appel de cgt et de fo avec des
blocages notamment à proximité des
dépôts pétroliers
c'est le cas la raffinerie de coignières
où le mouvement a débuté peu avant 4
heures ce matin
l'image de patrick jacques de dixmude 26
personnes syndicalistes étudiants
étaient présents n'est pas de routiers
les manifestants souhaitaient leur
parler mais empêché par la police qui a
fait évacuer les lieux vers 10 heures ce
matin
l'idée de ce blocage filtrant
initiale qui était de pouvoir discuter
avec les routiers qui se rendait sur la
plateforme pour leur expliquer pourquoi
c'est intéressant de se mobiliser
actuellement notamment à l'appel de la
cgt de fo de leur profession et vu que
les crs ont bloqué la route les l'action
aux camions pour s'y retrouver
on peut tout seul dans l'actualité
également la rentrée du côté de
l'assemblée nationale les députés
yvelinois de la république en marche
était ce matin rassemblés à maurepas
pour une conférence de presse au
programme le point sur leur permanence
leurs différentes commissions mais aussi
le calendrier des lois à venir prochaine
étape le projet de loi des finances qui
sera présenté ce mercredi en conseil des
ministres écoutez à ce sujet nadia est
député de la 11e circonscription membre
de la commission des finances au micro
de mélanie poker lé climat social fait
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut grandir
c'est que il est provoqué par certains
donc effectivement voir jean luc
mélenchon et son groupe la france
insoumise qui ont décidé effectivement
de créer des tensions pour perturber les
débats
donc comme à leur habitude ce qui nous
étonne pas puisqu'ils ont déjà procédé à
de cette manière là au sein de
l'hémicycle
donc nous allons
présenté ce projet le mener jusqu'à son
terme de façon très sereine puisque nous
savons qu'il est basé sur sur des sur un
triptyque gagnant alors les triptyques
s'est libéré protéger et investir
c'était les dernières élections de cette
année 2010 est 170 sénateurs ont été
élus ce dimanche 24 septembre dans les
yvelines six sièges ont été pourvus
le détail de ses résultats dans le
département avec nicolas landry de la
rédaction tv 78 bonsoir bonsoir grigris
alors quels enseignements tirer de ces
élections sénatoriales dans le
département
alors je vous propose de voir les
nouveaux sénateur des yvelines et c'est
quasiment un grand chelem pour les
républicains
la liste de gérard larcher a obtenu cinq
sièges sur les six au renouvelable
une victoire logique au vu de la
composition du corps électoral
le président du sénat a été réélu tout
comme sophie primas un résultat salué
notamment par la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse sur son
compte twitter comme vous le voyez à
l'image de son côté la république en
mars décroche le dernier siège avec
l'élection de martin le vrillé à ce
propos écouter aurore bergé porte parole
du groupe la république en marche à
l'assemblée nationale elle était au
micro de mélanie poquet ce qui n'était
pas évident c'est que nous on réussisse
à avoir des élus aux sénatoriales
parce que la république en marche vous
le savez bien n'existait pas au monde et
municipales en 2014 n'existait pas au
moment des départementales ou des
régionales dont on a eu quand même des
grands électeurs des élus venant de la
gauche venant de la droite ou sans
étiquette qui ont fait le choix de la
république en marche nicolas vous avez
parlé de la droite du parti présidentiel
également la république en marche
qu'elle est le résultat de la gauche
pour ce scrutin alors rappelez vous
grégory la gauche yvelinoise détenait
deux sièges au sénat avant ce scrutin
elle n'a pas réussi à les conserver
faute sans doute à la multiplication des
candidatures à gauche le parti
socialiste arrive néanmoins en troisième
position mais elle n'a pas obtenu assez
de voix pour obtenir un siège
je vous propose d'écouter la sénatrice
sortante socialiste catherine tasca
c'est certain que la multiplication des
listes c'est vrai d'ailleurs dans
beaucoup de départements a été mortel
il ya notamment à gauche réflexe serait
suicidaire puisque toutes les formations
concernées se sont trouvés dans
l'incapacité de négocier des accords
saad et moi en 2011
j'ai fait ma liste avec l'ensemble des
formations de gauche et le résultat
était là parmi les nouveaux sénateurs on
retrouve également en michel laugier
effectivement le président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a été élu sénateur dans la
liste les républicains et il a déjà une
idée sur la manière dont il va exercer
son nouveau mandat
écoutez le moi je compte ne pas changer
je suis représentant des élus locaux
bois bon c'est cette expérience là que
j'ai pu avoir à travers des différentes
fonctions qui va me permettre de pouvoir
voter de les lois les améliorer et faire
avancer notre pays
du coup nicolas c'est automatique avec
la loi sur le non-cumul des mandats qui
est entrée en vigueur le 1er juillet
dernier michèle losier va devoir quitter
ses fonctions de maire de montigny le
bretonneux également le président de
l'agglomération alors pas d'automatisme
puisque la loi stipule que michel
laugier dispose de 30 jours pour
notifier sa démission au préfet se
posera alors la question de la
succession de michel laugier à montigny
le bretonneux et à la tête de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
dans l'après-midi des voix se font déjà
entendre le conseiller communautaire
othman nasro appel je le cite à
l'organisation d'une primaire interne au
sein de la majorité afin de fixer les
orientations de la seconde moitié du
mandat communautaire fin de citation
mais il ya déjà des noms qui circulent
notamment pour la présidence celui du
maire d'elancourt jean michel fourgous
ou celui de la mère de plaisir joséphine
coleman ce berger merci nicolas et pour
être complet sur ce sujet un conseil
municipal doit se tenir dans la soirée à
montigny le bretonneux et un conseil à
d'agglomération aura lieu ce jeudi 28
septembre
transports la ligne 23 du réseau fébus
compte désormais un nouveau venu un bus
100 % électrique conçu par alstom qui
circule désormais sur le réseau reliant
vélizy
à versailles lancement ce matin pour une
phase de test d'un an sujet de vous
nicolas landry et aussi de camille
lambert 12 mètres de long 2 100 km
d'autonomie et des allures de tramway la
mobilité s'offrent une nouveauté plus
écologique dans les yvelines 100%
électrique
ce bus pourra transporter une centaine
de voyageurs les premiers et parmi eux
le maire de versailles sont plutôt
conquis et là tous les aspects d'un
wagon de tramway c'est à dire des
fenêtres qui sont plus basses donc une
visibilité parfaite sur l'extérieur le
tram ou et c'était très séduisant jeu
guerrier ya dix ans mais aujourd'hui la
vraie modernité c'est d'avoir les
avantages du tramway avec les avantages
du bus et là on en a la démonstration
est donc on est très contents de servir
de lieu de démonstration un lieu de
démonstration qui s'étend de vélizy à
versailles sur la ligne 23 du réseau
fébus conçu par alstom ce bus nommé à
petit ce est une concrétisation de la
région ile-de-france en faveur des
transports
c'est la région qui a à travers
l'ile-de-france mobilité qui a investi
dans ce premier prototype mais parce que
pour l'instant c'est qu'un prototype on
a la chance de l'avoir pendant un an
en test grandeur nature c'est un
investissement de
6 en euros équipé d'une dizaine de packs
batteries le bus et recharger tous les
soirs son originalité ses quatre roues
directrices à l'avant et à l'arrière
elle change la conduite par rapport à un
bus classique mana ori analyse sa prise
en main pour former les futurs
conducteurs
il va avoir un gros temps d'adaptation
aux conducteurs pour le prendre en main
parce qu'on n'a pas du tout la même le
même positionnement sur la chaussée dû
au fait que les roues sont sunu le
cockpit conducteur est légèrement décalé
vers le milieu du coup on se positionne
pas de la même manière sur ligne droite
si le test est concluant les premières
livraisons de ce modèle auront lieu en
2019 une ligne de bus qui je le rappelle
relis vélizy à versailles la cité royale
qui accueille justement demain une
conférence exceptionnelle créer du lien
c'est à partir de 19h au salon d'honneur
de l'hôtel de ville
événement organisé par le réseau
entreprendre yvelines bonsoir patrick de
1 to soit directeur de cette association
avant de parler de cette conférence
réseau entreprendre yvelines a été créée
en 2009 un acteur d'utilité publique
elle fond quelles sont ses missions
réseau entreprendre dans les yvelines
crémaillère les entreprendre yvelines
est une association de chefs
d'entreprise c'est vocation est
d'accompagner des créateurs et
repreneurs d'une façon strictement
bénévole et sans prise d'intérêt ce qui
veut dire que les membres adhérents
l'association cent des chefs
d'entreprise des patrons de pme des
dirigeants de groupes voire des
professions libérales qui adhèrent à un
message fort qui est considéré qu' un
chef d'entreprise qui réussit un peu
plus de chance que d'autres et donc il
est sain de restituer à des plus jeunes
restituer un petit peu de cette chance a
dit plus jeunes d'ailleurs vous avez une
conviction c'est pour que pour créer des
emplois il faut aussi créer des
des employeurs l'objectif majeur de
cette association pour tout en france
c'est d'aider à la création d'emplois
par la création d'emplois dans les
yvelines par exemple depuis 2009 on a
contribué à la création création ou
sauvegarde pardon de un peu plus de 1200
à 1300 emplois ce qui commence à être un
chiffre un peu significatif dans le
département alors vous proposer aussi
des accompagnements réseau entreprendre
venaco propose ses accompagnements quels
sont justement où et ses accompagnements
que vous l'apport que l'on fait aux
créateurs d'entreprise après les avoir
sélectionné qualifier l'apport est de
3,3 trois dispositifs le premier c'est
une aide financière par un prêt
d'honneur sans intérêt sans garantie qui
est apporté aux créateurs c'est un prêt
de vingt à cinquante mille euros qui a
pour objectif de créer un effet de
levier par rapport à ses fonds propres
puis la deuxième chose plus importante
c'est l'accompagnement par un chef
d'entreprise en activité qui va
rencontrer notre lauréat tous les mois
de façon structurée pendant une période
de deux à trois ans le dernier élément
du dispositif c'est qu'ils ont réuni nos
lauréats tous les mois de façon à leur
permettre d'échanger sur tel ou tel
thème ou de partager des bonnes
pratiques et des expériences alors
revenons-en à cette conférence demain à
créer du lien qui est une première du
genre pour réseau entreprendre yvelines
le réseau le contact le lien oui c'est
quelque chose de primordial pardon pour
pour les chefs d'entreprise
effectivement cette conférence de demain
soir s'inscrit dans le cadre de du fil
conducteur que l'on a retenu pour cette
année 2010 est à savoir créer du lien
pourquoi créer du lien on pense que
c'est vraiment un fondamental pour nos
jeunes entrepreneurs il faut créer du
lien avec ses collaborateurs c'est une
façon de donner une âme une entreprise
en création il faut créer du lien avec
ses clients ses fournisseurs de façon à
instaurer la confiance ce qui est
indispensable au démarrage d'une
activité puis crée du lien aussi avec
ses banquiers ses partenaires dans la
mesure où là
la transparence et la relation
personnelle sur un élément de
crédibilisation du projet donc c'est
dans ce sens qu'on a retenu comme thème
cette année le thème de créer du lien
un mot pour terminer sur les deux
intervenants de demain deux invités de
marque animeront cette conférence
d'abord michel podolak qui est chef
d'orchestre et et conférencier pourquoi
pourquoi programmer un chef d'orchestre
sur ce genre d'événement leur
effectivement dans le thème créer du
lien pourtant un chef d'orchestre du
bien si vous avez le bonheur participer
à cette conférence vous pouvez le voir
l'idée de michel podolak est de
considérer que des musiciens sont des
d'aidé individuelle et que pour arriver
à faire un orchestre symphonique qui
ressemble à un vrai orchestre
symphonique il faut d'abord savoir créer
du lien entre eux de façon à pouvoir les
animer les diriger et donc le deuxième
invité ces fronts que pruvost qui est un
créateur non-voyants l'entreprise
sencities wise est donc là il va
apporter ou bien on peut dire un point
de vue original un point de vue unique
sur le sujet alors nous avons demandé à
franck pruvost qui est donc non voyants
d'apporter sa vision du lien à créer
dans les entreprises franck a choisi
l'entrepreneuriat après avoir été major
de hec à l'âge de 21 ans
il aurait pu comme tous les majeurs de
la chaussée brillant aller dans un
groupe du cac 40
exercer ses talents il a choisi
l'entrepreneuriat ce qui était
évidemment pas la chose la plus facile
pour lui et cette conférence créer du
lien c est demain à partir de 19h au
salon d'honneur de l'hôtel de ville de
versailles merci patrick gauvin n'avoir
est avec nous directeur de réseau
entreprendre yvelines et pour plus
d'informations sur l'association vous
pouvez vous rendre sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
comme chaque mois sur tv 78 les dossiers
thématiques de la rédaction cette
semaine nous nous intéressons au
logement étudiant premier focus ce soir
sur la cohabitation intergénérationnelle
une personne âgée qui accueille un
étudiant chez elle reportage de nicolas
landry
elles cohabitent ensemble depuis 15
jours étudiante en licence
d'environnement ambre s'est installé
chez lui s'il pour cette année scolaire
un binôme formé par l'association
spécialisée dans le logement
intergénérationnel ensemble2générations
elles sont toutes les deux assez
indépendante mais je trouve qu'elle est
jeune belle connivence qui s'installe je
sentais qu'elle pourrait très bien
s'entendre parce que très ouvert toutes
les deux très respectueuse du planning
de chacun et puis en se donnant des
rendez-vous temps en temps pour partager
des dîners lucile prépare un voyage à
berlin
l'étudiante n'hésite pas à lui donner
des conseils pour son séjour
ensemble2générations a déjà constitué
650 binôme dans les yvelines depuis la
création en 2006
trois formules sont proposées pour les
étudiants et les seniors soient les
étudiants sont logés gratuitement en
échange de présents ce soir et la nuit
sinon on a une autre formule où
l'étudiant va rendre des services
et là le jeune va payer une petite
participation aux frais d'usagé
d'environ 80 100 euros par mois pour
couvrir les frais de gaz électricité et
puis notre formule où le seigneur a
besoin d'un complément de revenus ou des
content aussi d'avoir une présence dans
la maison
ambre a choisi cette dernière option
elle paye un loyer inférieur à 300 euros
alors j'ai choisi ce genre de logement
parce que déjà d'un point de vue
économique c'est beaucoup mieux
et aussi et surtout parce que ça me
permet d'être en colocation avec
quelqu'un et de pas être tout seul
l'étudiante dispose de son étagère dans
la cuisine pour ses produits
alimentaires dans sa chambre et là des
meubles pour ranger ses affaires
j'ai fait ma déco perso bâtir et j'ai
aussi une petite salle de bain et ça
c'est super parce que j'ai aussi mon
indépendance au niveau de la salle de
bain c'est juste quand je sors je là
prévient le week-end combat comme ce
week-end où je vais sur paris je là
prévient aussi pour vous dire que je
vais pas rentrer dans le week-end
seulement lui s'il va passer le week-end
tout seul depuis 2010 elle accueille
chez elle des étudiants pour
l'association ensemble2générations je
pense que bâchée difficile pour eux
aussi de se loger
bien que moi je ne je n'offre pas
logement gratuit
pour moi c'est c'est une bouffée de
jeunesse ambre depuis le peu de temps
kelly là elle m'a déjà aidé sur internet
parce qu'on a eu des problèmes de
connexion elle est beaucoup plus à
l'aise quand je suis en liga avec avec
la les dépanneurs ambre a aussi aidé
lucile pour remettre en place la
jardinière sur le balcon en 2017
ensemble2générations a déjà formé plus
de 75 binôme dans le département à
plaisir l orne désormais trois immeubles
du vally bout les fresques géantes ont
été inaugurés samedi par la mère
joséphine coleman ce berger en présence
notamment de pierre bédier président du
conseil départemental des yvelines
projet d'embellissement du quartier
enfin terminée après un coup d'arrêt en
2015 faute de financement ces dessins
muraux ont été menées par cité création
en collaboration avec les habitants et
des rénovations des immeubles du vally
bout intérieurs comme extérieurs sont
prévues jusqu'à la fin 2000
18 toujours samedi mais à maurepas ou la
ville s'engage pour son marché
le maire grégory galeristes et le
conseil municipal sont venus à la
rencontre des habitants et des
commerçants
l'objectif promouvoir la consommation
locale afin de connaître les attentes de
chacun
un questionnaire a même été distribués
c'est pour connaître un peu leurs
habitudes
combien de fois ils viennent par semaine
et ce qu'ils viennent au mercredi matin
le samedi matin ou deux fois par semaine
est-ce qu'il vienne véhicules et
qu'elles sont pour eux les atouts
majeurs du marché de mort pas ce qu'il
manque également parce que l'objectif
c'est de le dynamiser
c'est également d'enclencher jaillir une
nouvelle dynamique sur ce sur ce marché
juteux ya la concurrence comme je le
disais qu'ils se développent et
l'objectif c'est de rénover la halle et
donc d'apporter un plus pour faire
perdurer justement c'est tellement très
dynamique pour la ville de maurepas
elles sont le premier démonstrateur
d'agriculture urbaine en économie
circulaire les ferments ville de saint
cyr l'école ont reçu le prix défi urbain
dans la catégorie villes durables nature
productive remis par le groupe inova
presse il récompense les projets de
villes durables le démonstrateur a été
mise en place par l'association le
vivant et la ville on en parle tout de
suite avec alexis lefebvre ou bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes chef de projet à le
vivant et la ville alors l'association
est ce qu'on appelle une grappe
d'entreprises qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement
concrètement c'est des acteurs du monde
du privé qui s'associent pour créer des
innovations et on a à la fois des grands
groupes et des pme qui
à la fois du monde tous dit j'arrête du
monde du vivant mais avec des
complémentarités c'est à dire qu'on a
des experts du sol des experts de l'eau
des experts agricoles et tout ça
réfléchit ensemble pour développer des
démonstrateurs mais tout ça dans quel
but du cou et ses objectifs dévoile à
développer ces démonstrateurs le but de
tout ça c'est de créer des marchés et on
est vraiment dans une grappe
d'entreprises dans une forme associative
chacun donne de son temps mais vraiment
dans le but de créer des innovations
pour ensuite atteindre des marchés et
développer se développer un peu partout
en france
alors depuis 2014 le vivant et la villa
a mis en place ce premier démonstrateur
d'agriculture urbaine à saint cyr
l'école qui est coordonnée coordonnées
par le bureau d'études est mise en
oeuvre par les jardins de gallica les
quelle était l'idée finalement derrière
au moment de cette création
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on a
au sein de cette grande entreprise
quatre acteurs qui se sont mis ensemble
et pour développer ce projet de
démonstrateur ces quatre acteurs celle
veolia ses hydras sol sol paysages et
les jardins de gally qui sont
mandataires et donc l'idée r tout ça
c'était de montrer que sur un terrain
vague une friche abandonné t1 vraiment
laissé à l'abandon depuis plusieurs
années c'était possible de se remettre à
cultiver et produire des tomates des
fraises des framboises et d'avoir des
activités complémentaires que je vais
vous expliquer aussi on va présenter ce
site dans un instant à recevoir ce prix
du coup défier robin trois ans après la
mise en place de ce démonstrateur
j'imagine que c'est aussi une preuve du
travail bien fait bah c'est une forme de
fierté pour les équipes parce que
sur sympa de se dire que les projets qui
sont développés sur les yvelines font
référence et pourront peut-être demain
être dupliqué sur d'autres territoires
donc ces voix là c'est les projets
agricoles
c'est des projets avec des pas de temps
qu'ils sont sur le moyen long terme donc
trois ans ça paraît long pour des
projets de start up mais en fait c'est
pas si longue ça par rapport à des
temporalités agricole c'est juste le
temps nécessaire pour avoir en fait
trois saisons de culture encore trois
printemps successifs pour commencer à
faire des premiers calculs et et voir si
le projet est duplicable alors pour
présenter le site on est sur une
parcelle réhabiliter d'environ quatre
hectares qui a été roulée d'une ancienne
décharge
exactement exactement c'était quand on
est arrivé ici c'était des voitures
abandonnées des pneus des déchets de
béton etc
donc on a tout nettoyé d'accord on a
tous défricher et ensuite on s'est
retrouvé avec un terrain avec des
montagnes russes dans tous les sens ça
c'est un travail qui a pris combien de
temps par exemple en tout j'irai tout le
projet a pris deux ans être développées
et en deux ans on est passé du terrain
vague à la ferme qui propose aujourd'hui
trois espaces qui propose trois espaces
exactement donc le premier espace dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure c'est un
lieu de production c'est à dire que
notre métier c'est avec des gens de nos
équipes c'est de produire pour cueillir
pour vendre et donc tout est vendu en
circuit court dans les villes où l'on en
fait aux alentours un tout et tout et
principalement dans les yvelines ça
c'est le premier métier le deuxième
métier c'est de la location de jardin
serre qu on a 80 jardin mis en location
est disponible à tout le monde en fait
vous louez 50 mètres carrés de jardin
pour 50 euros par mois et vous avez un
petit lopin de terre
vous venez cultivez vous avez
deux possibilités de tisser des liens
avec vos voisins de parcelles dans une
ambiance qui est super sympathique et
et ça fonctionne super bien d'accord et
le troisième volet du projet c'est une
zone pédagogique pour faire découvrir au
plus grand nombre ce que c'est que
l'agriculture hors sol alors sur le
premier espace de production maraîchère
hors-sol ya plusieurs productions des
fraises et framboises des tomates
cerises des herbes aromatiques
quelle est la production juste pour un
ordre d'idée parents que on est sûr
c'est le tonnage ce qu'on fait par an
c'est à peu près 20 tonnes de production
d'accord vingtaine de production du mois
de juin au mois d'octobre principalement
donc ces trois gammes 3 4 gammes de
produits différents tous vendus en
circuit court
donc je dirais que c'est un peu la haute
couture c'est à dire que 20 tonnes c'est
quand même une production qui est notre
anecdotique et derrière c'est des
équipes qui sont là les vendre voilà des
indépendants des restaurateurs des
entreprises de services pour que tous
soient écoulées au plus proche de nos
bases un espace pédagogique aussi c'est
important ou être transmettre exactement
et c'est c'est bien la complémentarité
des trois métiers qui fait que le projet
est développé dans l'agriculture urbaine
et fait sens sert qu'on a à la fois de
la production bon le projet est crédible
parce qu'il produit et donc c'est bien
de l'agriculture le projet dans la
transmission parce que on a une zone
vitrines avec des techniques ont fait
découvrir à des scolaires et enfin le
projet dans le partage parce qu'il ya
toute cette zone de location jardin où
là c'est les portes qui sont vertes et
vous louer un espace et vous venez
partager avec des gens qui sont
passionnés comme vous pour le jardinage
donc derrière question on l'a dit à
cette initiative a bien sûr été
valorisés par le prix défier robin quels
sont les prochains objectifs pour les
objectifs c'est continuer notre
essaimage serre que m'ont montré que
cette solution fait sens par rapport à
la friche
vous avez aujourd'hui en france des
territoires périurbains qui sont
gangrénés par des friches
voilà je pense au nord de la france je
pense à l'est même à l'île de france où
il y avait un certain nombre de friches
importante ces solutions crée de
l'emploi sur le territoire
ces solutions apportent de la valeur
sens où vous avez un terrain vague d'un
habite et qui du jour au lendemain
devient fréquentable par le plus grand
nombre
donc voilà donc c'est tout ça qu'on veut
essayer de dupliquer pour que d'autres
français puissent en profiter
merci alexis lefebvre d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle chef de projet à le
vivant et la ville et pour plus d'infos
sur le démonstrateur les ferme en ville
rendez vous sur le site internet
www.lafarge.com et du sport pour finir
ce journal avec le mythique paris
versailles hier la course à pied qui
relie la tour eiffel à la cité royale
célébrer cette année son 40e
anniversaire
au total à 25000 courageux étaient au
départ de ce 16 km très sportif et
michael et demi d'euros sur des images
de patrick jacques de dixmude dimanche
24 septembre 10h25 mille concurrents ont
pris le départ de la 40e édition du
paris versailles au niveau du tracé pas
de changement en 2017 ce 16 km relie
comme chaque année la tour eiffel à la
cité royale en passant par me do et la
redoutable côté garde
peu importe à lier à laquelle on va on
est toujours en difficulté dans la côte
des gardes si on perd un peu de vitesse
après faut relancer mais c'est une super
course un super parcours les supporters
géniaux et donc moi j'ai adoré cette
course est rien par d autres parce que
c'est une course de haies de ville et à
la forme à 100 livres de toutes façons
forêt on a de la cause du décès
c'est la meilleure course parisienne
pour s'entraîner pour faire des
paiements chez les garçons l'éthiopien
getty neigé d'amour remporté cette 40e
édition les réalise un temps de 52
minutes et 50 secondes le premier
français est thierry guibault termine 2e
en 53 minutes et 12 secondes après avoir
mené une grande partie de la course je
pensais pas faire deuxième
il est plus fort accepter mais je suis
très heureux l'ethiopie et réalise le
doublé avec la victoire de schalke
zidane & gas en 58 minutes et 13
secondes chez les féminines la sportive
devance la française garde blot de près
de deux minutes
je suis absolument ravi et ce n'est pas
un objectif donc c'est une super
surprise en rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une 41e édition la
compétition devrait une nouvelle fois
tiré 25 mille concurrents sont les
organisateurs ce qui fait du paris
versailles l'une des courses les plus
suivis en ile de france
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
retrouvez tous nos reportages et le
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv et 78 bonne soirée
et excellent de semaine à tous
[Musique]